KEYBANK CENTER IN DOWNTOWN AGAI
HINOSTROZA.
COZENS CHARGES IN AFTER IT.
DEFLECTED IN FRONT OF THE NET,
AND THE TORONTO MAPLE LEAFS WITH
THEIR
ONCENTO THE CORNER
BUT KEPT IN BY MANNERER WHO GOT
IT OUT IN FRONT.
REBO BLOWING ]
>> Rick: COMINGMES TO SKINNER A
DOWN IT.
ASPLUND BEATS HIM TO THE PUCK.
SHOVELS IT INTO THE CORNER. GIV.
ANOTHER SHOT OFFF AARON DELL AN
A PERFECTLY PLACED SHOT HERE AND
HE STACE  THE
LEAFS AND FIRED INTO THE NET AS
BUNTING HAMMERS IT HOME, AND SO
THERE WON'T BE A  HANDLED CLEAN.
HE'S UNDER PRESSURE.
FROM THAT POINT ON, THAT'S
TAGE THOMPSON, HE RIPPED THAT
BABY HOME, AND BUFFALO'S WITHIN
ONE. THE RELEASE RIGHT THERE.
IT GOES RIGHT THROUGH THE L
BRODIE.
BRODIE BANKED IT TO CENTER ICE.
TO THE BUFFALO LINE ANDWHEN HE
BUT THE LEAFS
AND TAVARES, ONLY MANF THE YEAR
BUT LOOK AT HOW QUICK.
HE ALREADY KNOWS HE EE THERE.
HE
HE  RIFLES IT CROSS-ICE.
CLEARED.
AND A GREAT C
THE PUCK GOES BACK IN BEHIND
CENTER ICE, BUT THE LEAFS GET IT
BACK AGAIN A THROUGH.
SEE MATTHEWS RIGHT ON TOP